do you ever get into altered states
while you're in the wild not
because you've ingested something but
because of the experience itself let's
say it's meditative
well or perhaps maybe because of
injustice but um we can talk about that
later
yes i have
yes i have altered states as deep
uh as when i invoke the use of say plant
medicine or something like that no not
not as deep
but i blame my own personality for that
i'm a stub i can have a bit of a
stubborn
uh angle to me and so i've never truly
really gone into
great altered states through meditation
i know that it's incredibly valuable and
many people can i've tried for many
years i'm sure a teacher's out there
going i could show you how to get an
alternate state i get it i totally get
it um
no i think my altered state in nature is
more of a gentle one where i just
feel at peace so see to me rather than
practicing a technique of meditating
while in nature i'm just allowing myself
to be
in nature and that is the meditation
mm-hmm
what is it you said that there's some
stubbornness that prevents you from
using meditation to get to an altered
state what do you mean by that
i don't know um maybe it's like you
started asking questions about filming
bigfoot and i said you know i like to go
in as a very open-minded skeptic um
my my i mean through any seeking i've
done spiritually in my life
uh the
prayer side of that
and the meditative side of that
has never been one that truly
affected me
the people who have that affect them all
the time say oh you're just not fully
giving over yourself no that's not it
you know it's like that's great it
affects to you
great but i've tried very hard
and
it's just not and that's why eventually
later on in life when i went down the
road of working with plant medicines
that broke through in a massive way in
definitely a life-changing way so
so
meditation and i
were not a perfect fit and now let's be
careful on this see the thing is
people can listen to motivational
speakers or spiritual this
a lot of times what those speakers
forget yeah
is that we all have these much different
personalities
and a speaker often speaks to you like
you should have their personality
right all the type a's the tim ferrisses
and the tony robbins of this world speak
to you like
here's what i do and every morning i get
up and i have my journal and this is
what you've got to do you really want to
be a success just let's go can i can you
know can i get an amen right cold shower
i'm like you know
well i do do the cold showers but that's